(Hudson cooing)
TORI: Wesley's being so quiet.
JIM: I know. He's being so good.
TORI: If the kids aren't crying,
things are good.
JIM: Yeah.
We got a tailwind.
It's a paddler's dream.
TORI: Yeah, just my concern
is just the wind
past this point, basically.
JIM: I know, it's looking like
it's gonna pick up a bit.
A little wind is like
a gale force.
What do you think about
trying something out
like rigging up a sail?
TORI: Is that gonna just take
more time than just paddling?
JIM: If I can find
the right materials,
we could rig it up pretty quick,
and we're gonna have
to probably want to stop
to feed the kids anyways, right?
TORI: If we're stopping
for lunch, I suppose,
yeah, we could try to rig it up.
HUDSON: Ya!
JIM: (in Cockney accent)
What a nice little spot, eh?
Go on, guv'na!
TORI: Right into the rocks.
(scrape)
JIM: Wee!
TORI: Boom!
North. Here.
HUDSON: Wee!
JIM: Aww.
TORI: Huddy, you want
some lunch?
JIM: Hey, hon, can I go grab
a couple sticks
to rig up the sail?
TORI: Sure. Yeah.
JIM: Okay. I'll be back soon.
TORI: Yup.
JIM: If I don't come back,
never remarry.
TORI: Did you hear that?
It is a little windy out there,
and so I'm sure the sail
would be a good idea if
the wind stays in our favor.
But if it changes, it could be
a little bit tricky.
JIM: I'm gonna have to take
a couple small saplings.
So, I don't just walk into
the woods and cut down
the biggest, perfect tree
standing right in the middle.
That's a tree that's healthy
that's gonna live
for a long time.
So, they're gonna take those
from a spot
where there's a whole bunch
growing close together.
And that way, if I take a couple
and thin it out,
more trees will live
to become mature trees.
There we go. I think that'll be
just about right.
HUDSON: Dada!
JIM: I found pretty much
what I think are
the perfect things for the mast.
TORI: Sweet.
JIM: Yeah.
I am just lashing up these two
long, whippy pieces of sapling.
That is actually going to be
the top of the mast.
Yeah, it's gonna be...
pretty cool!
So, what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna lash them to the gunwales
by wrapping a rope around
the hull of the boat.
And that's almost gonna
create like an arch.
And then I'm gonna tie
a camping tarp to a stick.
Put a pulley in the top,
and that way,
we can drop the sail
if it gets too windy,
so we'll know that we'll be
safe out there as well.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay.
TORI: Whoa!
Ready to set sail, honey.
JIM: You know, it's a little
upsetting that Huddy's asleep,
though, and he hasn't
really soaked in
the brilliance of this sail rig.
He'll have to enjoy the
pictures, unless he wakes up.
We'll see, though.
TORI: Ah, good boy!
JIM: Okay. Okay, you ready?
TORI: Okay. Let's do it.
JIM: Alright,
I'm gonna raise it.
TORI: Alright!
Ah!
JIM: Yeah! It's working!
TORI: Yeah! Woo-hoo!
JIM: Woo!
TORI: This is great!
We're sailing!
JIM: Okay, cross draw.
Cross draw.
TORI: I am cross drawing, honey.
JIM: It's working!
We could technically sail all
the way to the end of this bay
effortlessly with
the tailwind, eh?
TORI: I know,
I've got my feet up.
JIM: Just saving energy,
it's saving time.
TORI: We're doing it.
Too bad the kids
are both asleep.
We should get into
sailing, honey.
JIM: Yeah.
Bam!
TORI: Boom!